en provence alpes côte d'azur à chaque
élections régionales l'extrême droite
joue les trouble fête
c'était déjà le cas lors du tout premier
scrutin en 1986 à l'époque pour se faire
élire à la tête du conseil régional jean
claude gaudin et la droite veulent faire
alliance avec le fn
un appel reçu cinq sur cinq par le parti
d'extrême droite
il y a des discussions par personne avec
un parti politique est toujours débat
des amis des amis qui veulent du bien
aux amis des amis
c'est comme ça que ça se passe pour
l'instant et l'alliance se confirme le
21 mars 1986 grâce aux voix du fn et
lors d'un débat houleux
jean claude gaudin est élu à la tête de
la région ne vois d'un élu du front
national ne vont-elles pas une voie d'un
ami de monsieur marché en retour jean
claude gaudin sommes deux membres du fn
vice-président de la région
six ans plus tard en 1992 nouvelles
élections
gaudin se représente et à droite la
question d'une alliance avec le fn se
posent encore
mais le chef de file de l'udf là sur
cette fois l'extrême droite ne jouera
pas les arbitres j'avais dit avant le
scrutin
et depuis plusieurs mois que je ne
ferais pas d'alliance en particulier
avec le front national
jean claude gaudin est réélu mais sans
l'appui du fn 1998 il ne se représente
pas c'est françois léotard la nouvelle
tête de liste à droite pour lui hors de
question de s'allier avec le fn alors
que certains élus de droite veulent le
contraire toutes les suffrages des
genres qui sont élus
démocratiquement sont bons à prendre
donc ils viennent c'est bien évidente
finalement et pour la première fois la
région paca bascule à gauche
mais le fn renforce ses positions près
de 23% au second tour en 2010 c'est le
pénix qui renaît de ses cendres n'est ce
pas voilà à tel point que le ps se
désiste au second tour en 2015 le parti
appelle à voter en faveur du candidat
des républicains
christian estrosi le but faire barrage à
marion maréchal-le pen qui est arrivé en
tête au premier tour avec 40% des voix
s'est servi de lui
cette année c'est de nouveau la division
à droite le parti se déchirent
christian estrosi vient de claquer la
porte des républicains
et toute cette confusion pourrait bien
profiter au rassemblement national
[Musique]